là quand je suis allé me coucher j'étais
mordre
[Musique]
mon père a vava va tombé dans l'alcool
et qu'à partir de là la vie bascule quoi
la mienne et celle de ma mère aussi
puisque évidemment mon père à un alcool
on va dire triste et agressif et qu'à
partir de là quand quand ils rentrent le
soir par un soir sur deux un soir sur
trois voit le la moindre petite faute
est prétexte à bas une rafale de coups
qui s'abattent sur moi sans que je
comprenne ma raison quoi c'est pas la
fessée là on n'est pas dans une fessée
voyez la fessée est insupportable la
raclée on est encore dans un domaine
supérieur c'est-à-dire là vous êtes
recroquevillé dans l'escalier c'est à
dire que votre dos il est il des marbrés
et vous avez votre petite soeur elle
assiste à ce à quoi
c'est ça la maltraitance elle est où
dans physique que psychologique
ce qui était terrible après ces moments
douloureux c'est que j'allais me coucher
et après mon père venait me voir après
et me disaient qu'ils m'aimaient et
après il ya la peur mais c'est pas la
peur de rencontrer quelqu'un qui va vous
tapez c'est la peur de prendre l'avion
c'est la peur d'eux
d'aller sur un terrain inconnu c'est la
peur de faire fort boyard pendant près
de 20 ans est de trouver chaque année
une une excuse pour pas le faire
jusqu'au jour où vous vous avouer que
allez on assume on le dit voilà j'ai
peur de ceux ci j'ai peur de cela et
tout et puis comme vous avez des idées
des gens qui vous aiment suffisamment
bas ils vous disent allez viens faire
fort boyard on va s'arranger et aime et
je les fais mais c'était incroyable
c'était une émotion terrible pour moi
les gens qui me demandait mais mais
pourquoi vous disent rien pourquoi vous
en parliez pas mais je répondais tout
simplement parce qu'un enfant ça aime
ses parents un enfant ça protège ses
parents et oui même s'il est battu
parce qu'un enfant à sa construction
c'est de se dire que peut-être qu'il a
fait une bêtise et que quelque part il a
il a mérité
donc il n'a pas les moyens et les mots
pour aller voir une autorité supérieure
la seule la seule preuve qui pourra
témoigner de la violence qu'il subit
c'est d'avoir des marques des coûts et
là j'espère j'espère que l'instituteur
le professeur des écoles la personne qui
s'en apercevra alertera voilà les
services sociaux
y'a que ça mais n'oubliez pas une chose
très importante
un enfant battu il revient pas forcément
le lendemain à l'école avec un oeil au
beurre noir
non non non
[Musique]
un enfant battu il prend des coups dans
les côtes
[Musique]
je suis né à 17 ans puisque cette année
là je vois passer mon bac et j'adore
j'adore mon père qui rentre vers 9
heures du soir et un moment que je me
bouge dans une plaie des bruits
cavalcade comme ça dans l'appartement
je comprends pas trop donc tu veux je me
serais je sors de mon lit je j'ouvre la
porte qui mène au couloir et la voilà je
vois mon père avec un fusil et voilà
mais qui tient ma mère on joue et là
j'ai juste le temps de dire mais papa
qu'est ce que tu fais quoi
mais mais les mots les mots ont du mal à
sortir
donc évidemment il se reprend qui
pompait sa carabine et puis s'en suit
une scène qui est une scène est violente
et triste
oui me fait asseoir dans un canapé pour
pour me réciter toute la tristesse qui
est la sienne et ça aussi c'est
psychologiquement voilà ça c'est de la
maltraitance puisque la lan il évoque
tout son malheur tout ça toute sa
tristesse tout ça tout ça
sa rancoeur et qu'après pas vous avez un
sac à dos sur les épaules que vous allez
travailler comme ça pendant pendant des
années et ce sac à dos ben je les
trimballer pendant des années jusque on
m'a dit en dix ans après le médecin que
je voyais régulièrement parce que je
faisais des crises de spasmophilie parce
que je faisais de la tétanie parce que
je pouvais pas rouler dans une voiture
sans tout à coup je devenais paralysé
toutes les facs marais des façades
sonnerat cauchemar donc le médecin qui
était un médecin assez génial maison
le médecin généraliste comme on en rêve
me dit à un moment donné peut-être y moi
je peux vous donner des médicaments des
plus je pense que là il faut vous alliez
discuter quoi il faut il faut il faut
vous alliez parler et à partir de là
j'ai commencé à faire tout un travail ce
ce dont je parle c'est à dire qu'on peut
s'en sortir et parler avec vous
aujourd'hui la condition d'être
courageux et de faire un travail si on
peut le faire et j'ouvre une parenthèse
et je la referme
parce que moi tout l'argent que j'ai mis
dans ce travail de psychothérapie et d'
analyse je l' ai pas mis ailleurs gelé
gelé investi pour essayer d'aller mieux
et je les fais pour mon entourage parce
que ça aussi
voilà voilà elle est là la résultante de
ce que clament à la maltraitance sur sa
propre vie et sur la vie des autres
parce que parfois les autres peuvent ne
pas comprendre pourquoi vous réagissez
comme ci ou comme ça donc j'ai fait ce
travail là et puis paradoxalement
puisque mon père était aussi ce que
j'écris dans le livre à un mec
formidable
après cet événement de deux de mes 17
ans mon père va me trouver une place
l'été à la maison de la radio
c'est lui qui me voilà qui me fait
rentrer paradoxalement dans cet univers
qui m'amène jusqu'à vous aujourd'hui
[Musique]
oh
les enfants il faut entendre leur voix
par leurs cris et là dans le monde
entier lance moment c'est catastrophique
et voyez j'ai pour pour conclure je vais
vous lire un article publié par le monde
il ya cinq jours en france
un enfant tué tous les 5 jours par ses
parents ou leurs proches
voilà et je me dis ça c'est c'est pas
possible quoi c'est là je suis un peu
désarmée à un moment je dis ça mais moi
si je peux être utile à travers mon
discours à travers les conversations que
j'ai avec les gens à travers ce que je
ferai à travers les diverses missions
qui seront celles qu'on m'attribue rage
c'est parce qu'on me proposera je le
ferai je le ferai parce que un petit
enfant ça mérite pas ce à quoi